Our fourth principle was a Knowledge Based AI agents match methods to tasks.
At the beginning of this course we covered several very
powerful problem solving methods like Generate & Test, and
Means-Ends Analysis. But because they were very powerful and very general,
they also weren't necessarily the best for solving any one problem.
We also covered some more specific problem solving methods like planning
that addressed a narrower set of problems but addressed those problems very,
very well. We also covered several tasks in this class, like configuration and
diagnosis and design. These tasks could all be carried out by a variety of
methods. For example, we can imagine doing configuration with Generate & Test or
we generate every possible configuration of a certain plan and
then test to see which one is best. We could also do configuration by
Problem Reduction where we reduce the problem down into the sub parts and
solve them individually and then compose them into an overall solution.
In this way, knowledge based AI agents match methods to tasks.
In some cases we do the matching, we decide that generate and
test is the best way to address this diagnosis problem. In other cases we might
design AI agents with their own meta-reasoning such that they themselves can
decide which method is best for the task that they're facing right now.
Note that this distinction between methods and
tasks is not always necessarily absolute. Methods can spawn different sub tasks,
so for example, if we're doing design by case-based reasoning that spawns new
problems to address. And we might address those new problems,
those new tasks, with analogical reasoning, or with problem reduction. This gets
back to our meta-reasoning notion of strategy integration. In this way,
knowledge based AI agents match methods to tasks not only at the top level, but
also at every level of the task-subtask hierarchy.